okay so good afternoon everybody thank
you for coming to this talk i would like
to thank the organization of these
wonderful conference on having a great
time so far and also I Oswald for
encouraging me to submit start to the
conflict because i met him in Pike
ensuite and three weeks ago actually
we're like doing some kind of european
tour python conference lately so we end
up meeting everywhere this like the same
kind of people every time so well right
now i'm going to talk about the Jupiter
formerly ipython notebook because most
of the people have been using it without
knowing it or knowing more or less and
the tutorials is pretty famous but
nobody has explained it so far what is
it exactly about what was the history of
the bleep row yet so I'm going to see
the opportunity to talk about a bit a
little bit and this is not going to be
very very technical not about data
science for machine learning more about
the history of the braid why it's
important in the open science movement
which I'm very interested in too and at
the end of the talk if I have time i'm
going to show a demo with some some
hints of what can we do with the ipython
noble and this multi language
capabilities how can we combine
different languages with the same
interface so there we go well first of
all let me introduce myself I'm an
aerospace engineer at heart while in
reality I haven't finished my studies
yet I'd love to finish them in September
hopefully I'm a self-taught Python
program because we'd used to study some
programming at the University with
fortran 77 everybody was not enough for
some purposes so i started in developing
a growing interested in python and
becoming more and more involved into
into the community specifically we we
writing a blog called by vanity about
scientific computing in Python in
Spanish language my twitter handle is
over my head just in case you want to
follow me um I'm also the chair of the
Python Spain Association where we
organize the Python Spanish conference
which is going to be the third division
this year in Valencia
just in case you want to come it's
probably the cheapest Python conference
in the world I I promise yeah this is no
no joke am I also finishing our
internship in our separation where I
develop all sort of Python applications
and I have a personal project which I'm
going to talk about in the lightning
talks just in case you want to come but
all I want to say right now it's about
rocket science so please don't miss it
and talking about things that orbit
let's get to the point now I would like
to introduce in the first place and
energy that I like very much to justify
why is important the ipython notebook
have you ever heard of the Russell's
teapot anybody okay some of you well
it's a metaphor proposed in 1952 by the
English philosopher Bertrand Russell in
the context of refute ability of
arguments or statements or whatever the
only reason for it to be a teapot is
probably because Russell was English had
he been Spanish it would be Garcia's cup
of cafe con leche or something later so
basically Russell suggested this thing
if I say that between the Earth and Mars
there's a teapot orbiting around the
sound in an elliptic orbit but I say no
you cannot observe it with even the most
powerful telescope on earth well then
there's nobody that can prove it right
or wrong right and and this was in the
context as I said of refuge ability of
an argument this example can seem a bit
weight or out of context but you will
see that many authors think they refute
ability of an argument is what makes the
line between what is and what is not and
we're going to see a very clear example
of our resist a pot in the 21st century
so in May 2010 to economics from the
Harvard University carbon ring her and
koenig row of publish an article in an
issue without a peer review of the
American economy review the claiming
that when a country rich in ninety
percent of level of depth about this
gross domestic product its economy would
recess okay in 2008 was the financial
economic crisis which was still very
recent and this kind of argument was
used all over the Western world to
justify austerity measures its best
into your southern neighbors I think you
know what I'm talking about but however
in 1505 23 32 15 almost three years
later there was another team in the
Massachusetts University who was begging
for the original data and the original
and I see saying you know what I'm this
conclusion singer it way to me I would
like to see the original analysis and
well after three years they found out
that this come this Congress were
basically rubbish because they were
using like great w's mythological
project procedures are very strange
statistical arguments and there was an
emetic mistake in the Excel spreadsheet
so if you being cut your salary lately
you can thank it to XL ok so this team
Paris the data and the analysis are
publicly online so everybody could
reproduce the art program that is used
for the counter analysis and see what
were the conclusions that were drawn for
the for the study but even so is there a
better way like we can mix the text
display nations the analysis decode well
it turns out that there is so enter the
ipython notebook by the way I just added
some astronomical pictures just because
I love them um well the ipython notebook
what is it exactly well it's an
interactive Python interpreter in just
the ipython thing but the ipython
notebook is an interactive Python
interpreter on the browser ok it's an
open format tool in the ne side just a
JSON document where you can mix text
multimedia code that you can execute and
gain and change it's inspiring the
mathematica notebooks if anybody has
used them and is biased ah well in the
first place in on the Python programming
language well just an as an addict
though like some months after the
country Alice disappeared the Fernando
page which is the creator of the a
better look notebook asked on Twitter
about someone doing the analysis in a
notebook format in like two hours later
you already had it so you can already
browse it and
see the conclusions of the Ranger and
row of study in a night by phone book
format the power of the ipython is that
it provides as I said ah let's say a
method to combine all these information
together so for me it's been a perfect
tool to do courses on Python premier
language I've been teaching Python to
iron optical and aerospace graduates on
chemical engineering and stuff people
that are not used to tools like MATLAB
or no tool at all excel stuff like that
and there are many many courses palace
in this format that you can that you can
really follow about for example
navier-stokes fluid dynamics in
numerical methods and this very famous
book about probabilistic programming and
by easy methods for hackers and the
thing is that last year in October the
nature the NATO scientific journal which
is one of the most important is not the
more important in life science publish
an article about the ipython notebook
and about its importance not only in the
way that scientists were carrying their
work and doing the analysis but also
because of the importance that it had
when they wanted to share their results
not only with with other peers but also
with the public should provide to be a
very very nice format to share all these
results well many more articles follow
about the not only the use of Python or
the ipython notebook but emphasizing
that you can use any other open source
tool to carry the job and that most of
the times you can combine them in very
nice ways as we will see bit after that
but before seeing some practical results
I would like to address some meats or
some strange coincidence that I have to
face when people in big companies or
people that are not used to the open
source tools ask me from time to time
for you perhaps there is no no problem
with this but I think still many many
questions in big companies about what is
the point of upper source office it's
really reliable so well
stovall is that there is no support
right because this open source tools are
made by volunteers that weakens when the
children are sleeping so I cannot like
call anybody on the phone when I have a
problem the other one is that it won't
be free forever for some reason I've
been asked this question a couple of
times and they wonder okay this tool is
free now but how do I know that it's
going to be free forever and and the
other one is that free software has bugs
as the same thing as I said before like
if they are programmed by volunteers
then I have no guarantee that they have
any quality measures or any thing to
assess that this always works properly
so in the first place this thing that is
no support is no longer true like we
already know that there are many many
companies doing super and doing business
using open source so there is no more
question about that fortunately this
thing about not being free forever I
think many of you know the history about
mysql and maria de Bay openoffice and
LibreOffice from the time that you
already publish a software online and
the that is open from that point it
belongs to the community so in the end
it makes no sense to wonder if he's
going to be free or not because if a
company tries to retain up tries to
close and it's over then anybody can
change the name take the call and go on
with the project and the free software
has bugs well yes obviously yes I think
nobody has done this but it has bugs
because of its freedom well also in
October 2014 there was a very funny
article written by three Spanish
mathematicians called the misfortunes of
a tree of mathematicians using computer
algebra systems computer system I just
for those who don't know system to carry
on any kind of symbolic on analysis very
complex mathematical tasks and they were
trying to compute the determinant of
very very large integral matrices and
they were doing the same competition
with Mathematica and with maple and they
saw the with Mathematica like they wrote
the calculation in one line it was in
the get a result and if they repeat
exactly the same calculation the
following line they would get a
different result
so they were very worried about this
because you don't know what result do
you want to trust and they ask your
friend reset and they said okay we have
a problem with this software and the
company has answered okay okay we are
aware of it thank you very much we're
going to physics in the bed in a ganache
back soon and we didn't they didn't fix
it so it was another version of the
software released but it still had the
same bag so these researchers could not
use this over any more so the moral of
the story in the end is that software
has bugs like it's a material if it's
free or if it's not free and the sooner
that we understand that the process of
creating software is a process full of
problems and mistakes and we have to
apply critical reasoning on it every
single time the bet is going to be for
all of us it's surprising that nobody
mentioned before but Bloomberg the
company that provides the venue for this
conference published our 38,000 word
article explaining what is code it's a
very very long read and actually I
haven't gone through it all still but
it's a very very wealthy article and in
the end well it writes about many
different topics like the beginning of
computing languages including some all
Fortran how do you make applications
what is this open-source thing and the
thing is that the following day the
police another article that say you know
open source is not a password we do it
every single day here so it's now a real
thing and there are many many movements
now of many companies in many
communities that suddenly they are
starting to shift the the way that they
they envision open source for example
there are a couple of piece of news that
I gather when I gave this presentation
in in Stockholm three weeks ago the
first of them is that you can now
visualize ipython notebooks directly on
github without using any other external
service which is great and the other one
like almost the sink well the same day
that you can now publish books on or
Riley which is
the technical books company publisher
that I we all love directly with an iPad
from notebook and if you think about
that is perfect because you can mix the
explanations with the code and you don't
have to i don't know what's the creation
process right now but i'm not sure is
not an easy a second be with these kind
of tools and this one I added some days
ago when Apple did the last conference
some days ago they just open sourced the
language that they were creating and
they announced their it's going to work
on linux like this is a very good piece
of news and well not to mention all the
movements that Microsoft has been doing
in the past also to shift towards open
source so in the end it's growing a much
bigger interest in in open source and
open source tools okay so when I had the
opportunity to talk with Fernando period
which is the creator of ipython like a
couple of years ago I was very
enthusiast enthusiastic in the at the
time and I asked him do you know do you
think that in the future we're going to
carry all the scientific computing in
Python all the data analysis and stuff
and he said of course not but why would
we know that way why would we need to do
that because we have many open-source
tools many languages all of them have
their strengths their weaknesses so why
not combine them all so this is the
philosophy behind Jupiter which is not
like the new incarnation of the ipython
notebook for the next version this is
going to be the branding and the name
and everything and if you say did you
see that it's a world play between Julia
Python and arbiter three different
languages very used in scientific
computing in the end they all separated
the language agnostic parts let's say so
the server the protocol and everything
and they created some components to link
the back end let's say to the language
that you are using so in the end you can
use the same ipython notebook interface
that we all know but with more than
thirty three languages last time I
checked and more surprises are coming
for example I don't know if anybody's
you have scurry away
any signal processes analysis in MATLAB
or something like that like well many
not many fortunately because I don't
like it very much well but you can use
Madame in the ipython notebook too if
you want there is an I matlab colonel so
if you want if you like the interface or
you want to convince your boss that
change into python is a good thing you
can say okay do you like this interface
these graphs so we can use exactly the
same thing with the language that we
already have so we don't have to throw
away years of ever and work that in the
end it's not worth it to throw away okay
so I not chat for now I think I'm on
time only so let's let's switch to add
demo to see how this works one going to
open now if LibreOffice allows me
is well you don't see it now you do is
the website or the nature a scientific
journal the day that they publish this
scientific article about ipython
notebook as you see here there you have
an iphone server running on an iframe ok
so let's go fullscreen ok and now here
have a notebook this is not running in
my in my computer because they have a
server somewhere else Rackspace provides
that even if i could correctly so well
there were some examples of things that
you can do with the ipython notebook I
don't know for example because I was not
in the tutorials and to how much of the
capabilities of the ipython nobody you
use but well for example this is like
the simplest thing that you can do do
you have a map your lip graph over here
nothing very special as you can see I
have all the text and all the equations
and everything and the equations display
nicely actually which is great a bad for
example here have gone an example this a
bit more complex which is related to
signal processing and data sampling and
stuff if I move this frequency slider
here then I consider in real time this
is updating the data from the map
Telegraph if I move this one here I can
change the number of grid points so it's
a way like if I would like to say ok how
does this look for 10 frequencies and 10
number of data points I would like to
make a hundred graphs but I don't have
to anymore because I can do some spirit
or analysis in an interactive way and
now with tools like bouquet and stuff
like that it's even more easier in
another very interesting example about
image processing that they have a
picture of a galaxy from the Hubble
Space Telescope and there they have an
algorithm to count the number of
galaxies so if you change the parameters
of the algorithm for example if I lower
this Sigma then we can see that the
number of galaxies appearing here is
changing ok now I have a lot of them
also if I lower the threshold
is changing to almost in well in real
time right it has to process everything
and get it back via web sockets well and
this is the ipython notebook as it was
published for the nature mm journal but
there are more things that we can do for
example wait a minute if you want to try
like the Jupiter notebook you can go to
that URL / try you Peter orgy and there
are another examples of notice that i
can use but we don't only have python
over here but we also have like even
haskell air for example let's open it
when I said you can see is the exactly
the same interface that we have before
but here i have our code okay i know
nothing about are so i don't understand
what i'm doing but i can still run the
code and provide the same interface the
graphics is still embedded into the
notebook and there is no change about
the the TVA the appearance of the
interface but these are third thing that
we can do which is even more interesting
no go back please it's a bit
uncomfortable oh okay I did it so if i
create a new Python notebook in this
case with Python 3 of course we're in
2015 already so if I import for example
numpy as MP do you see properly like
from the back or do I okay so if I
import numpy and I great an array for
example like X equal anything I concur
I'm going to copy the the code for
another example that I have here in our
block
No
this is screen is quite big okay here's
a nice an article that we published
about working with Python and are at the
same time in for example if I create an
array of points with these points mmm ok
they have an umpire ray and now I can
run any our code that I want here but as
I'm working in the Python language I
have to make a sweet so if I right here
are the president symbol twice and are
then whatever I right here is going to
be our code okay and the cool thing is
that i can introduce here are variable
like get into it the x variable which I
define outside in the Python side and if
I carry on the computation okay fine
define this Y and this summary I don't
know any are a nice throws now so pray
for anybody right so if I carry this
computation wait a minute because I got
to load an extension first not this one
wait minute
II what I have to load an extension that
I don't remember the name still wait a
minute
so
sometime it's coming I didn't write this
myself and it shows too so AHA here it
is ok I have to load an extension of
ipython which loads the additional
capabilities so ok well now as I wanted
to do here the art computation perform
like I it introduced the X variable
which was defined in the Python side i
get into the the our code ok because I'm
computing here this this thing and not
only I can push variables into the
competition but I can also pull them
outside so if I say for example that I
want the Y variable outside I can run
this cell again and if I go if I go here
if I bring why it's exactly the same
vector that I defined in the outside ok
so this is like a perfect way if I want
to mix cold in different languages I can
directly use the ipython notebook and
even exchange variables between both
sides okay so enough demo for today come
on
okay now some final remarks to wrap up
the and I talked you be there and I
Python a few cam scene is a very useful
to not only for coding but also for
sharing and exploring some variables and
analysis for teaching we don't have to
throw away previous work done in
different languages or with different
technologies because we can reuse all
that technology and open source in
general and Jupiter in particular is
gaining relevance inside not only the
business world let's say but also in the
open science movement and we must go
further than that so please the next
time that you want to publish our
scientific article with potential
consequences for their lives of many
many people no more teapots and thank
you very much questions if I was just
letting any package do I have to restart
the entire server or can I throw is
there any tennis ball packing thank you
but I just run paper today just reloaded
kind of that do it well you install a
new package like from the tanjo install
it you can next important in a new cell
and it's going to work if you change the
code of a package which is a different
problem there's another extension to
reload automatically the code so you
don't have to restart the whole work
again so yeah there's the tool the two
options is there any way in our present
say so in the netbook say you need these
packages to run this or know that I know
of the thing is that um well the first
solution would be to include all the
impulse in the first cell and it's
nothing is if something is not working
it's going to throw a network but still
they are working in some ways to extend
the noble and actually you can already
do it and you can add some custom fields
to the document itself so it there's not
a way to do that but it's it should not
be very difficult to create a way to do
some kind of things like that
whatever you want to add a new language
can you do you have to like write a new
the equivalent of Matt Matt would give
in line for this new language or you can
reuse the protein all languages no well
like the map you live in line thing is
some way of working that works for the
whole notebook let's say I'm being a PNG
and show them displaying the PNG but the
fact that you don't have a cutie window
which is open and you were asking if you
can combine both motes of working or I
didn't get a question no I meant let's
say we got an innovation you know
different coding library is there extra
work to do or it's easy to integrate in
principle it's easy to integrate I mean
I only work with Natalie because I
haven't taken the step to learn Sieber
or um any of these libraries buying
principal yet should be true bc
well in principle it should not like you
repeat the question yes ah you are
asking if in terms of reproducibility if
there's any difference of me between
providing injustice quit on any Python
notebook in principle there's not like
in the end it's everything it's cold and
they think that is going to provide you
your results it's it's the the problem
that you're executing the good thing
about the ipython is not the
reproducibility itself over a normal
script but the thing that you can share
and instead of in lining comments to
explain what are you doing you can
introduce text formatted text equations
and pictures or whatever look at one
last question
well I know that people people from the
Yulia yes sorry you're asking about
these hour 53 languages that you can use
many of them are proof of concepts well
I don't know exactly but I do know that
do you know the Julia programming
language it's a fairly new programming
language that appeared Taylor to
scientific computing but with very
modern ideas taken from different
languages and it's actually a big thing
now because they are even having their
first conference this year and raised by
it with the Python community by the way
and they are using right now the ipython
interface with the julia colonel to
provide all the older work so yes it
works I don't know about other languages
for example I know that the ER language
works fairly well too but about the
other 30 languages I don't know there's
even a fourth uncle but I haven't tried
because I try to write as less fortunate
as I can that sounds like you have some
battle scars from writing well are you
very much I Louise like thank you very
much